you're a belieber and you are a true
believer you love you some Justin Bieber
I'm told that you may have may have
committed a crime involving Justin
Bieber that you've never revealed to the
police and it's time to hear it now
before you're out of time go gosh okay
well I went what if my friends works for
him is on his staff and hopefully not
outing him but he invited me to go see
his concert so I was able to go
backstage and everything and so every
city he goes to he's a big hockey fan
right they make two hockey jerseys for
him that are like all for him beaver on
the back with six for each place so it
was in San Diego and it was just sitting
casually on the chair and everyone was
leaving after the show my friend was
like what so I literally put it under my
jacket and stole it
you stole Justin Bieber's hockey jersey
and it's that's his hockey jersey no I
know but they said he gets one made
every city's like how many hockey jersey
and they you know really one for each
city
[Applause]
no she made that up for the story that
there's two so it doesn't seem like such
a bad crime that's why I love that your
justification is my friend was like just
take it just take it well that I mean
anyone could come up to you in any
situation you and I could be diamond
shopping and I could say just take it
just that's one of my weaknesses I'm I'm
very naive like if someone's like oh
just do it like I had a really terrible
New York shadow Cavs story where someone
was like Huijin I'll take you to
wherever you want to go and then I walk
up it's a van with no windows and duct
tape and
have you heard of this of shadow cab no
I haven't it's very scary so what
happened I bet if she met that shadow
cab guy now you'd be like you remember
me right
[Applause]
you